para conocer el enésimo o cualquier
término de una sucesión podemos
identificar su expresión general la cual
no es más que el conjunto de símbolos
que nos dicen lo que está pasando en una
situación relacionada con números vamos
paso a paso tenemos la siguiente
sucesión 25 10 17 26 y 37 lo primero es
ver cómo va cambiando nuestra sucesión
recuerda que lo hacemos identificando el
patrón o regularidad
al analizar la sucesión podemos ver que
la diferencia entre un término y otro es
9 y 11 fíjate muy bien que identificasen
estos números exacto en las diferencias
hay un patrón de dos porque tres más 255
más 2 772 es 9 y 9 + 2 es igual a 11 un
tip cuando las diferencias entre un
término y otro tienen un patrón la
expresión general para encontrar
cualquier término será cuadrática
decimos que es cuadrática cuando al
menos una de sus literales está elevada
al cuadrado así que si la sucesión que
tenemos es cuadrática la expresión que
nos ayude a encontrar cualquier término
de la sucesión tendrá al menos una
literal elevada al cuadrado
una expresión que cumple con estas
características es la siguiente en e
iguala en al cuadrado más x no te
espantes vamos a comprenderla juntos la
n es el número de la posición por lo que
al sustituir la va cambiando 1 2
456 etcétera
antes de encontrar cualquier término de
la sucesión probemos nuestra expresión
sustituyendo el primer término que ya
conocemos y ese es el 2 esto nos ayudará
a saber si estamos utilizando la
expresión adecuada para el primer
término sustituimos el número de la
posición que representa es decir la n
por el 1 y quedaría de la siguiente
forma
a uno es igual a uno al cuadrado más
equis pero en nuestra expresión tenemos
un signo de más sumando una equis esa
equis significa que podemos sustituirla
por cualquier término que queramos para
obtener como resultado los términos que
ya tenemos en la sucesión con lo que
acabamos de sustituir si lo dejamos
únicamente así el resultado es 1 porque
uno al cuadrado es 1 y nuestro primer
término es 2 entonces qué número se te
ocurre que podamos sustituir por la
equis para que al sumarlo al 1 nos dé 2
pues claro un 1 veamos cómo queda si
sustituimos la equis por un 1 a 1 igual
a 1 al cuadrado más 1
y si lo resolvemos 1 al cuadrado es uno
más uno y obtenemos dos excelente
verifiquemos n igual a n al cuadrado más
1 es la expresión adecuada sustituyendo
los demás términos si funciona sabremos
que nos servirá para conocer cualquier
término a 2 igualados al cuadrado más 15
a 3 igual a 3 al cuadrado más 1 y el
resultado es 10 a 4 es igual a 4 al
cuadrado más uno y es igual a 17 para 5
al cuadrado más uno tendremos 26 y ya
sólo nos falta un término a 6 es igual a
6 al cuadrado más 1 y obtenemos 37
funciona esto quiere decir que la
fórmula que planteamos nos ayuda a
calcular cualquier término de esta
sucesión busquemos el término 70 es muy
fácil sólo tenemos que sustituir el
número 70 en nuestra expresión al igual
que lo hicimos con los términos
anteriores
por lo que lo expresamos así a 70 es
igual a 70 al cuadrado más 170 al
cuadrado es igual a 4.900 más 14 mil 901
perfecto no dejes de practicar y
vuélvete un experto en sucesiones